spectateurs 100 l'atp chez vous attends
je suis pas prêt bonjour cher public
nous allons ce soir vous interprétez
trois pièces mesdames messieurs voici le
grand méchant renard non c'est la
troisième fois cette semaine ça suffit
non mais c'est parce que j'ai faim en
fait je m'en fiche
pourtant j'ai tout fait comme toi c'est
à dire tu sais le truc que tu fais à cet
âge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa maman non mais je suis pas une
bouille
sept dépôts ta vie tu devrais avoir peur
de moi silhouette un peu colère mais
paie toi tu vois pas j'essaie de te
sauver la vie bon j'aurais essayé pour
vous ça ont tenté de mordre certains de
leurs petits camarades il aurait essayé
de dévorer me ciel rien n'était et c'est
à partir de maintenant en donner des
adultes responsables et enfin ils
tombent surtout fini les way you lie
gamineries maman va casser la figure au
vilain monsieur c'était bien excellent
[Musique]
est ce que tu veux bien que tu paies à
michel et je m'en occupe si tu veux ça
ne me dérange pas du tout non mais ça va
s'appeler partie
[Musique]
lui tellement peur de perdre
t'en fais pas maintenant on arrêtait
betis bon allez en route
tu vas voir comment va livrer ce bébé
accroche toi comment ça démarre ce truc
[Musique]
camion voilà ce que c'est moi qui a
qu'un et c'est moi qui convient
benamor tiens donc voilà
non merci
le bébé pauline et ou elio pas ici là
non plus mais aurélie ou la bouline
grrrr
ou c'est moi le plus grand et le plus
méchant des renards mensonge c'est moi
le boss c'est moi le grand méchant
renard j'avais enfin te donner la
correction que tu mérites france à un
marc au fac un [ __ ] ça mais ça a tout
un crime devant la puissance ton pied
non non tu as les fiches mois le conseil
prend ton temps
ça va
c'était mon toit le premier show von ah
oui c'est vrai mais l'or ça vous dit ça
veut dire qu'on est des bonnes armes en
a 6 1
vous rendez compte on est les enfants du
grand méchant renard il créatures les
plus fortes et les plus méchants mais
non vous êtes des poussins et poussins
les neiges où les débats vous êtes des
poussins vous devez avoir peur de moi
j'ai eu très mal
non j'en ai peur de toi ça suffit j'en
ai assez je veux plus vous voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]